hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 196 is it 196
it is the 196th live stream I am Dr
Brett Weinstein I am of course sitting
with Dr Heather H as so often as for all
of our live streams and uh we
are well frankly a little
discombobulated because um things are
moving a pace in the world and uh uh
takes a lot of processing but in any
case we um we have quite a number of
interesting things to discuss today
we've got a little business to take care
of up top what have I missed you're
looking at me like I missed something
normal and essential just waiting for
you to wind down okay to wind down
that's as if there's a spring in me that
has perhaps a little too much tension
but it's possible that is true for all
of us at the moment it's uh yeah it's a
it's a rough moment for sure so come
join us on Rumble if you're watching
somewhere else uh subscribe to our
Channel there please uh if you're
watching Live join the watch party at
locals at locals you can also find early
release of guest episodes of Darkhorse
private monthly Q&A which we're doing
tomorrow it's uh the It's usually the
last Sunday of the month at 11: a.m.
Pacific we're doing a little early this
month because we're going to be
elsewhere uh we've got amas uh Zach and
I did an AMA uh Brett has done them we
have access to our Discord lots of stuff
going on at locals we encourage you to
join us there
uh and uh we're not doing a Q&A after
this live stream today but we will be
doing this private Q&A tomorrow and then
we will be doing a Q&A after our next
live stream which is this Tuesday rather
than Wednesday after which we will have
three weeks uh without any live streams
but there will be a couple of guest
episodes dropping during that time you
will have to hold your
questions during that time uh what I
thought we were maybe going to do some
amas during that time actually you won't
have to hold your questions but stay
tuned for information on when you can uh
open the pressure release on your
questions I I I'm going to I'm going to
get on my game here any moment you'll
see so as always we have uh three
sponsors at the top of the hour uh
organizations products that we actually
truly vouch for without further Ado
let's begin
those our first sponsor this week is
biome maker of knobs
NOS knobs is a new kind of denus deneris
is anything you use to clean your teeth
toothpaste or powders or knobs knobs are
fantastic biome that's biome without the
e on the end is focused on transparency
safety and efficacy of its products it
is truly fantastic let's talk fluoride
fluoride is the anti-cavity ingredient
in most toothpaste that you already know
about but as we discuss in our book The
fluoride and drinking water and
toothpaste is not in the molecular form
found in nature nor has it ever been
part of our diet and ever more research
is pointing to the neurotoxicity of
fluoride exposure especially in
children knobs from biome does not
contain fluoride but unlike competitor
products knobs does include a different
far better remineralizing agent knobs
uses hydroxy appetite hydroxy appetite
is the main component of the enamel in
your teeth and it is in your bones as
well it is as effective as fluoride in
remineralizing teeth without the
toxicity of fluoride hydroxy appetite
doesn't merely stop cavities from
forming it can even arrest tooth decay
once it's underway wow knobs also has no
abrasives like charcoal or B soda and
has no sulfates parabens phalates
microplastics no BS it's right there in
the name furthermore knobs comes in the
form of a dehydrated tablet which allows
them to be shelf stable without
preservatives take a tablet chew it uh a
few times and then brush as normal your
teeth are going to feel fantastically
clean because they are also unlike
toothpaste TSA has no interest in knobs
because they're tablets so if you're
flying with knobs you don't risk losing
your D to security so check out knobs at
www.be T rbo
m.com Darkhorse that's better biome
without
the.com
Darkhorse listeners can enjoy 15% off
the first one month supply of knobs so
go to better
[Music]
biome.is indeed and they've actually got
um many people prefer a minty taste in
their in their Denis as do I but they've
got a new flavor which if you're not
someone who uh craves mint in your D
they've got a vanilla flavor that um I'm
something of a connoisseur of vanilla
having lived in one of the vanilla uh
producing capitals of the world in
northeastern Madagascar um and while I
prefer mint to vanilla uh it's actually
quite compelling so they've got more new
flavors as well now I have yet to try
that I will say say at some point at
some point when the world is not doing
uh so many appalling and difficult to
understand things we should have a
conversation about why it is that we
read mint as synonymous with clean and
fresh anyway I think that's kind of an
interesting conversation to have but all
right I
digress our second sponsor this week is
Maddie's all-time favorite you may hear
her snoring in the background although
if she knows what we're talking about
she'll probably wake right up it's
Sundays Sundays makes dog food but it's
not your usual DED dog food this is no
standard issue burnt kibble still the
standard highend burnt kibble that we
were feeding Maddie seems to please her
well enough she's a labrador Labs will
basically eat anything what possible
difference was she going to show an
interest between her usual kibble a
widely available high-end brand and
Sundays we were wrong Maddie loves the
food that Sundays make seriously loves
it and uh you were just noticing this
morning when you were feeding her uh
that uh she knows when she's getting the
The Sundays and she Hops and skips and
Twirls and dances it is really true that
she I think recognizes either the bag or
the velcro closure something about it is
pavlovian and causes her to know that
this is uh this is the good stuff this
is going to be a really good meal yeah
um Sundays is the first and only human
grade air dried dog food air drying
combines the best of cooked and raw
approaches like raw air drying preserves
nutrients and taste better than high
heat methods better than raw though
Sunday's unique air drying process
includes a kill step which kills
pathogens so unlike freeze-dried raw or
frozen raw dog foods there is no food
safety or handling risk for Sundays
combining the nutrition and taste of all
natural human grade foods with the ease
of a zero prep ready to eat formula
Sundays is an amazing way to feed your
dog there's no fridge no prep no cleanup
no gross wet dog food smells it's a
total pleasure for the human interacting
with it which is a bonus Sunday's has no
artificial binders synthetic additives
or other garbage all of Sunday's
ingredients are easy to pronounce and
healthy for dogs to eat in a blind taste
test Sunday's out performed leading
competitors 40 to Z and our own little
anecdote Maddie or labador or supports
that
results do you want to make your dog
happy with her diet and keep her healthy
try Sundays we've got a special deal for
our listeners receive 35% off your first
order go to Sundays 4dogs Darkhorse or
use code Darkhorse at checkout that's s
n dys s f r
dogs.com Darkhorse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you are feeding
your
dog our final sponsor this week is seed
a probiotic that really works if you've
tried probiotics before and got nothing
of it try seed it's designed differently
from other probiotics it's designed
better it actually works seed helps
improve the health of your gut
microbiome which means that it supports
you becoming healthier overall our
resident gut microbes directly impact
the development and function of the
immune system even before we're born
microbes inform our immune system
teaching our body how to distinguish
between benign substances and pathogenic
antigens that is substances that our
body doesn't recognize as its own you
can support your gut immune axis in a
variety of ways including by
prioritizing sleep new research suggests
that the gut microbiome has its own
circadian clock and that changes to your
normal rhythms can disrupt your microbes
and the important functions they perform
thus prioritizing regular sleep can lus
can lus that's a lot of luses uh can
help keep your gut immune AIS healthy
seeds dsl1 daily synbiotic also supports
your gut immune access seed is a
plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic with
24 strains have been clinically or
scientifically studied for their
benefits 16 of those 24 strains are
specifically geared towards digestive
health and four 24 probiotic strains are
known to promote healthy skin your skin
like your gut has its own microbiome
seed supports both gut and skin Health
seed is free from 14 major classes of
allergens including but not limited to
sugar animal products soy gluten peanut
glyphosate Dairy shellfish and
corn and seed is basically double Hol
with its capsule and capsule design it
is engineered to maintain visibil
viability not visibility viability
through your digestive tract until it
reaches your colon where you want it and
the same design makes it resistant to
oxygen moisture and heat meaning that no
Refrigeration is necessary seeds daily
symbiotic supports gut skin and heart
health and micronutrient synthesis we
have heard from several people who have
used seed and Report improvements to the
just to function in 24 to 48 hours so
start a new healthy habit today visit
seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse to redeem 25% off your first
month of seeds DS1 daily symbiotic
that's seed.com Darkhorse and use code
Darkhorse awesome I have turned off my
device realizing that I forgot to do
that
before all right where should we start
where would you like ah um why are you
uh today we had an annular eclipse the
world did and um much of the world of
course didn't see it but in the US and
parts of the US it was visible and uh
here in Washington we didn't get 100% we
got about
80% and um it's just it's it's notable
to think about astronomical reality that
changes not a bit with all of the chaos
that we humans are creating down here on
Earth uh an annular eclipse in which uh
the new moon comes between the Earth and
the Sun thus obscuring part of the Sun
or if you were in the path of of
totality all of the sun um does depend
on you being on Earth but nothing that
we do down here changes um what it is
and that especially in these so trying
times um feels even more important than
ever to be thinking about things that
exist outside of Human Experience um and
you know it's it's I think it's over
everywhere now I think it must be
um but it's the experience is seeing the
sun become a crescent uh and and then
becoming unac Crescent unac Crescent not
accrescent again
uh and of course it's a shape that we're
accustomed to only seeing with regard to
the Moon in terms of um large
astronomical objects in the sky um but
it is is highly unusual and it raises as
do all eclipses and many other events as
well for me the question of what people
who lived in cultures without astronomy
without an understanding of astronomy uh
must have thought right and uh I think I
think the answers will be different
depending on how close to developing
astronomy they were you know the Maya
had astronomers in astronomy but I don't
know uh that their understanding of what
was going on extended to being able to
predict anular eclipses for instance nor
do I know to what degree the knowledge
of the astronomers the astronomer class
uh extended into the population so
whereas now anyone with the internet
could have seen that there was going to
be an eclipse and whether or not they
fully understand what that means they
could at least know was coming and not
go outside and be freaked out by what
they saw in the sky uh but this would
have been a very different experience uh
not so long ago for everyone on the
planet
um many many points in response one I do
think that there is something quite
comforting about the fact that this is
an event that is beyond human
interference yes and this is I hope that
this is not too dark uh perspective but
you know during the eclipse we watched a
raccoon who would not ordinarily have
crossed our yard in the day um trundle
across our yard could be just a
coincidence well he appeared to be
trying to steal
kayaks there is that but of course he
had that opportunity every other day of
the week and he didn't do it so um there
is the question about whether or not
yeah uh you know so let's imagine human
beings uh don't wise up anytime soon and
take themselves out
eclipses will still happen it will still
have effects on other creatures and even
if we as I fear were to take out higher
life on the
planet eclipses will still
happen 100 million years from now there
will be something equivalent to raccoons
that will be momentarily confused by
these things if an eclipse happens on a
planet bereft of life does it still
happen well yes it does it sure does
right and so you know it could confuse
microbes photosynthetic plants in ways
that would be totally uninteresting and
then it can confuse creatures with
cognitive processing because the event
so rare that they wouldn't have a
processor for it or whatever but anyway
there's something interesting and
comforting about that um that you know
even the universe is really just not
about us you know right um we we are we
are fortunate to have our position in it
but um we could screw that up and it uh
the universe will will hum along that's
right and I think you know this is a
point um a point that I used to make to
my and our students a lot and it's it's
how I opened up uh the story that I tell
of uh the boat accident that I was in
that almost killed me in galpagos
leading study abroad um which is that um
nature is and there are exceptions of
course sometimes you will have a runin
with something that very much wants to
get you right but in general nature is
not out to get you and the truth is in
some ways you know I find it a Rel
but many people find it at first
terrifying uh the truth is actually that
nature is indifferent to you mostly
right and uh astronomical events
demonstrate that and you know the closer
it is to both our space and our time
scale uh the more likely that truth is
to be muddied um that uh you know
obviously things like uh pathogens uh
who have you know an interest in uh
infecting a host uh you know the goal is
not harm the goal is their own success
so there is still kind of an
indifference even when um the
indifference on the other side uh means
that a win for them is a harm to you but
the goal is not the harm right and uh as
as you know but uh for listeners benefit
uh in my dissertation one of my
questions was why are species more uh
densely packed as you get to the equator
and uh part of the answer to that is
very shocking which is that as you get
closer to the Equator um The Selective
environment is dominated by things with
a contrary interest things that are in
one way or another hostile to your
well-being and that is in fact a more
hospitable environment than in the
temperate zones where the biggest
challenge is the arbitrariness of the
weather and that arbitrariness of the
weather is so difficult to deal with
because you can't rely on it to be
hostile right some days it Smiles on you
and the next day it frowns on you and
that arbitrariness is a destroyer of
species it's harder to evolve a response
to it so um what Dick Alexander um
mentored to both of us your graduate
adviser uh called Darwin's hostile
forces um really does divide importantly
along this abiotic versus biotic line
where the the abiotic stuff the weather
the climate the volcano the earthquake
right um not only does not know you
exist and can but it also cannot respond
to you there is no way that you can do
something differently to uh change what
it does you might be able to outwit it
outwit is the a weird word there because
there's no wit on the other side there's
no potential for wit on the other side
but you may be able to use your wits uh
to get around the problem that has
caused for you but there is no game
there is no enduring game there is no
back and forth there is no play right
and you know play can be very very dire
I use play sort of a technical use here
whereas if it's biotic there is the
potential for a a call and response for
a give and take for for uh for some kind
of interaction and uh you know we we
confuse those two things at our at our
Peril um we do and you know an investor
would understand this because in an
investment context let's say that you
you know you're running a a firm that
makes a something right you know who
your competitors are you have a rough
sense of what they will understand about
what they might do to get in your way
and you can plan for that future right
whereas let's say that you make the same
thing but the energy markets are going
to fluctuate with battles uh across the
globe that you can't predict because
those battles are responsive to
geopolitical events that are outside
your expertise or maybe outside of any
our ability of our ability to even
monitor the things that cause them to
happen how do you plan for that right
you you you've got you know production
ready to go and then suddenly your
supply of plastics dries up because you
know a pipeline is blown up by somebody
or a war starts and so anyway it's the
arbitrary thing that's harder to deal
with right your competitor is in one way
just simply reliable right you know you
know you can put yourself in their shoes
and you can plan accordingly yes unless
unless they begin acting out of spite
right in which uh they are willing to
harm themselves in order to do harm to
you
uh their actions should be predictable
and even spite can be predictable but it
does change the game yeah and in fact
there's one interesting place um so as
Heather points out despite the
definition and the technical definition
is the willingness to accept a cost in
order to inflict a cost and this is lots
of things are spite like policing we pay
to have a police force that's a cost
that we as a civilization pay in order
to inflict costs on criminals so that
they will decide not to commit crime
right so spite is an important mechanism
ISM I yeah spite prison uh police
prisons all of those disincentives are
costs that we pay because yeah I guess I
I would not think to classify it in in
in spite territory um obviously the goal
is to reduce the need for the thing that
you are doing whereas um you know game
theoretically you're right just the you
know as I said and then you said the
definition of spite is just uh being
willing to incur a cost to inflict a
cost um but if the goal is a long-term
reduction in costs all around um that
feels like it's not long-term spite it
well I mean the whole point is why is
there spite at all why would you ever
accept a cost to inflict a cost and the
answer is for long-term reasons so it's
sort of the you know it's the it's the
reason that we see the pattern and have
a name for it well you know but
individuals individuals behave in ways
um that really do seem to be simply
counterproductive for both them and the
individuals there's lots of maladaptive
Behavior or and that and that is very
often where spite shows up in a game
theoretic people are very often
especially in modern times where you
don't correctly perceive where your
interests are because you know you're in
a bar a thousand miles from home and
somebody says something insulting and
you don't understand that you there's no
conceivable gain that could be reached
by punishing them right that kind of
thing um but you almost sound like
you're speaking from experience which I
I don't think you are no I'm I'm pretty
good at staying out of bar fights for
various various reasons y um but uh
where was I going with the spite there
was some important point but I've now
forgotten what it was oh well about bar
fights
um I did I got it here's what it was
there's an interesting example of what
you're talking about about spite in the
business context that is actually
written into our legal structure okay so
anyway this is a weird conversation to
be having but um the there is an
antitrust provision which I think is now
not enforced very much antitrust was
effectively gutted I think during the
Reagan
Administration but there used to be laws
designed to facilitate good competition
and Stamp Out counterproductive
competition competition that destroys
wealth is bad there's no there's no
reason that we as a society should want
to see that kind of competition what we
want to see is competition that drives
us to innovate and make the pie bigger
um the antitrust violation in question
is you are not allowed to sell your
product at a loss in order to drive your
competitor out of business right a big
firm can sell its stuff so low that
nobody can compete with it because
you're taking a loss and the point is
you do that until your competitors are
all gone and then you Jack the price up
and you recover the money that you uh
lost in the early phase that's bad for
us all right it means that the market
doesn't get to set the proper price and
that we get gouged as consumers so
anyway um we uh tried to hedge that out
with spite right we make it a a crime
and we penalize you enough that you it's
not a productive Behavior to engage in
um which we don't do anymore but uh but
nonetheless it was it was an indication
of how civilization was really dependent
on wise spite being employed well I mean
it's it's it's tough to I don't I don't
know this history but I imagine that
economies of scale being what they are
you know large companies that sell a 100
products um would absent this uh this
what you ruling this piece of
legislation this provision um wanted to
be able to sell 10 products at a loss
because as long as the 90 other products
were selling at a profit they weren't on
balance selling at a loss whereas a
company that only sell 10 products can't
afford to sell half their products at a
loss right um but it's also true that um
if you're larger you are buying more and
therefore you are getting them at a
lower cost and so you can drive this the
your competitors your smaller
competitors out of existence uh without
taking a loss although you know so it
seems that a one toone comparison isn't
quite Fair because the profit margin uh
is is what ends up mattering and I have
no doubt that there is a huge amount of
case law arguing exactly that question
right is this an what I would call an
efficiency of scale but a normal person
would call an economy of scale oh thanks
man I it's just a pet peeve of mine but
um no I'm just uh I'm I'm objecting to
you calling me I know just in this one
regard but um but anyway I'm sure that
this has been argued you know if you
think about something like Amazon uh you
know if Amazon can spend 10 years losing
money and drive everybody else out of
the position of middleman so that
whatever you buy you buy through Amazon
then the we're we're it's for the
rest of Eternity right oh but they would
never do that I think they might um so I
wanted to if we can switch gears a
little bit out of the uh spite thing I
wanted to point out that this eclipse is
what is called an annular eclipse and
annular eclipses we I think the last
major one that we encounter maybe not
but I think the last major one that we
encountered we were living in Michigan
and it was total for us um yeah I mean
there' there've been several since then
anular yeah okay well uh the last one I
remember maybe it's maybe the weather
made it impossible to see them but I
remember the annular Eclipse was coming
and it's like oh you're going to be in
the path of a total eclipse but it's
annular what that means is that the Moon
by virtue of its distance from us is
small relative to the Sun so it doesn't
completely cover it and it doesn't turn
dark yeah the the the two distances
right you know distance from Earth to
Moon and moon to Sun yeah the relative
size of these two things in the sky
means so the moon May cross the center
of the Sun but it doesn't completely
close it out and because of the light
amplification capacity of the eye it
really doesn't get very dark at all um
but boy does the sun look weird boy does
the sun look weird but here's the thing
so I remember during that Eclipse sort
of feeling like oh that's too bad it's
not a real Eclipse right and so I was
kind of not even really thinking of it
then it happened and in Michigan you're
talking about yes and I remember
distinctly real realizing that the world
around me though not dark had changed
radically in a way that implied all
kinds of weird stuff about things that I
apparently had misunderstood every day
of my life until then are you going to
provide examples I'm going to provide
the one example that matters but it was
a million versions of it which was that
every place where light came through
trees or anything else became an image
of the eclipsed sun with the moon in
front of it yeah
and it was like I didn't realize that
every little block of sun that I was
looking at was a yes admittedly out of
focus image of the sun right I just
thought it was like a splotch of light
and here it was like oh God what did
this just imply and yes I live I live
among shadows and I did not know that
they were all individual Shadows
projections it's almost like you know
it's like a fractal Plato's Cave you get
out of the cave
you're out in the real world but you're
still in the cosmic cave looking at
Shadows on the wall so I mean I I
remember this too very intensely and I
remember later the first time I was
walking in some City uh at night and
came under one of those new LED uh
Street lamps that cast these crazy grid
Shadow things um and and I don't even
know how to describe them I probably
most Urban dwellers or Urban visitors
have experienced these now see you see a
reflection of the the LED array on on
the concrete and it's um it's ugly yeah
and it's disconcerting and it feels
dystopian and you know hyper modern and
the first time I saw it my first thought
was the only thing I've ever seen that
reminds me of that before was those
Shadows of the Sun during the annular
eclipse in Michigan and yet they are so
utterly different in origin yeah it's
like it's like pixelated light it's like
an insult to Nature right um you know
unlike a beautiful glow of even you know
an incandesent bulb or something like
that it just it's almost monstrous right
I think so yes aesthetically it's
aesthetically
monstrous um but the last point I wanted
to make about the annular eclipse and
the fact that it reveals this thing
suddenly is that um a you make an
excellent point I think that the
ancients if the Ancients were completely
inept with respect to understanding what
was going on in the sky then they would
be very caught off guard by an eclipse a
society that had begun to figure out
what the at least the pattern of
movements across the sky was so that
they could predict the pattern even if
they didn't understand what it was right
they might not predict the eclipse but
they would at least know where the moon
even though it is invisible to us at new
would be in the sky and they would be
able to say that must be the moon
Crossing in front of the sun right which
brings me to our little modern
predicament um where you and I have uh
now moved to a new place we have an
actual uh view of the Horizon for the
first time ever we've always lived in
Forest before right yeah but it has
revealed something about the motion of
the Moon that is indeed puzzling and I'm
doing a good job of not looking it up
because I'm enjoying trying to sort
through exactly how it works but the
basic observation where at let me just
interrupt you for a moment whereas the
sun rises um farther to the north the
closer to the summer solstice which if
you're in the northern hemisphere as
most humans are is in late June and and
is rising close farther to the South um
the closer to the winter solstice you
are that is a predictable trajectory
through the across the Horizon over the
Year yes but at each of the equinoxes
that's about equidistant between the
northernmost and the southernmost uh
rising of the sun which is going to vary
depending on where you are in the planet
latitude wise but um You can predict it
you can say okay you know if
it's if it's October it's going to be a
bit like it is in February and you know
and and and like that whereas yes so
it's a it's a an a sine wave across the
year um where you could say as soon as
you correct the calendar for the slight
error of the year not being an integer
number of days
you can say this at this moment in the
year the sun is always going to rise at
right at exactly that point at this
moment at this place at this at this
place in time right um the moon
obviously goes through its year around
the Earth in 28 days um what it does on
the horizon of the earth is nuts it is
it's nuts and it's not going to be that
you just have to understand that that
month is a moon year and fix it
because when the moon is new right when
the moon is new the opposite of full
that is because you are looking at the
Dark Side of the Moon it is on the same
side of you as the Sun but that happens
on the opposite side of the moon year
depending upon whether you're in spring
or fall right you're on the opposite so
the moon will be either fully lit or
fully dark at the opposite Point
depending upon where the Earth is in its
orbit but anyway the degree to which the
moon moves per night yes uh and rises in
a different place is absolutely
befuddling even though it's obviously so
thoroughly understandable that the
Ancients nailed this I mean you know
Venus is tough the Moon is not yeah
right but for us moderns Moon's actually
tougher than you think figuring out
exactly where where it is going to rise
so I you know since we now have a view
of a horizon and and a view of both the
sunrise and the moonrise because of the
way we face um
I actually at at for the three four five
six days um of the full moon and and
moments around it um will set my timer I
I will use modernity to help remind me
if I am not already out there looking at
it to make sure that I actually see it
if if the Horizon is actually clear
which of course for some months of the
year the Pacific Northwest The Horizon
won't be clear enough to see it but um I
I I sort of began thinking about this
when we moved up here and I would be
looking in one place like where where is
it and you know it's a big Horizon you
don't you don't miss it when it does
come up but often be like
wait over there what what happened just
last night it was okay yeah I will tell
our audience because they will find it
fascinating and bizarre um that when you
say your timer what that means in our
house is a arbitrary selection of frog
calls um and birds it's not arbitrary I
said yeah so I have well I didn't say
random it's arbitrary I have neotropical
um I have of course own um I've bought
uh and created but most of the ones that
I play on my phone are are purchased uh
bird and frog calls from the jungle and
so you get orop pendulos and various
frogs and so that's what my alarms are
set to in my timers um as well so that I
don't I don't get um crazy modern tones
from Apple I I I get to briefly imagine
that I'm back in the jungle and it's
really it's the Counterpoint to the LED
grids that you see in the shadows when
you walk in a modern city right this is
you know okay the alarm on a phone is a
modern modern phenomenon but what you've
done is the intrusion is now frogs from
somewhere which you know that ain't
normal but it's uh it's also not jarring
yeah and it's nice way to wake up oh
it's lovely and you know just
momentarily being called to some far off
place by some frog call that never hear
at home the orap pendula are a little
harsh but that's these uh black and
yellow uh Orioles they're related to
they're black birds big black Amazonian
uh all neotropical birds um and they
just um they're a little loud yeah
they're a little a little jarring yeah
yeah you want to hear I can do an orap
pendula call but I we've found actually
that orap pendula is veryy a tremendous
amount over their range so this is
really uh you've got the Central
American call with a at the end right
because in the
amaz that's right that's right yep that
is what they sound like yeah that is
what they sound like okay so the last
point I wanted to get to I have a note
to myself it says if I see that I even I
can read that it's only two letters and
it says if two letters I was able to get
through two letters without the dyslexia
overwhelming the note but
um the annular eclipse the one we saw
back in Michigan that made the
interesting projections on the ground
that alerted me that the normal
projections were more than I had ever
thought they were it's strikes me that
there's some list of
phenomena that
suggest parts of physics that are
not absolutely everyday experience right
the fact that an object drops when you
let it go is an absolutely everyday
experience that implies something about
physics it's very hard to understand
that all objects are attracted to each
other if that's true you know why do I
not feel this pen attracted to this um
this zebra and the answer is is because
gravity is such a freaking weak force
that you need something planetary scale
before you can even detect it it is
pulling this pen to this zebra but it's
undetectable by normal means you should
be glad now that gravity is not a
spiteful God because uh imputing
imputing its strength uh might come back
to haunt you well someday we'll do a
little exploration of gravity the degree
to which gravity is the key to
everything that doesn't seem that's it's
being driven by gravity is amazing and I
used to spend a lot of time uh pushing
students into that recognition um
pointing out how my uh bicycle for
example is powered by gravity fusion um
but again I digressed the point is there
are certain phenomena that one has rare
access to either in time something like
a rainbow yeah right which you never
know when it's going to happen but you
learn amazing things I saw an entirely
gray rainbow the other day oh wow
I it was extraordinary I have a I have a
picture actually which is on my phone so
maybe at some point you're talking I can
send it to Zack and he can show it here
um I've never seen anything like it
before but it was an arc in the sky and
a place that I've seen a full color
rainbow and it was so much fog and so
much cloud and I was biking through it
and I I I I don't know what explained it
right amazing so uh all right I'll I'll
give you one uh I was driving a couple
months ago and uh there was a rainbow
and as happens when you're driving and
there's a rainbow you know it moves
along with you which is fascinating um
but I realized something which damn it I
should have realized before
um uh what I realized was that the
rainbow reads as 5 or 10 miles
off because of a heris in the mind that
causes you to put it in the context of
mountains and buildings and things like
that as if it's a physical as if it's a
fix as if it's fixed in space well let's
put it this way I think it is almost
fixed in space but it's very close to
you is the answer right it's very close
to you and the way I figured that it
would be changing other things about
your Universe if it were that big and
close to you and followed the other
rules of what matter does right so it
it' befuddles you because it behaves
like a farway object the moon moves with
you when you drive in a car the rainbow
moves with you when you driving a car
that seems to imply a very great
distance yeah
um but no and the way this became
obvious to me was that as I was
driving the the Mist in the air that was
being broken up that was breaking up the
light and causing the the prism effect
was being intensified by the cars that
were driving around me they were kicking
up spray oh and here's here's the kicker
the spray the rainbow continued and it
was in front of the guard rails rather
than behind them so whereas it looked
like 10 miles away if I looked up into
the sky as it got near the ground I like
oh it's right there right um so anyway
the point is we each had a personal
rainbow a few feet from us you know and
we thought you know because I say look a
rainbow and then somebody you know 15t
from me says I see it too no actually
you're seeing a different rainbow right
right it looks identical but oh that's
good yeah it was pretty cool but anyway
there's some list imagine that you are
one of the the Blessed humans who had
lived somewhere in which there were some
rocks in your environment that were
magnetic okay right I thought you were
just blessed to have rocks no a lot of
people have rocks but yeah I feel like
that's true yeah so imagine you know oh
this is your gray rainbow yeah that's
actually that's interesting that picture
looks different from um it looks far
Bluer Than I remember the experience
being um and in fact I see some color
there uh whereas with the naked eye so
this is I'll just say I was biking and
this is at a place on Santan island
called false Bay uh where it's often
very foggy when it's no it's not foggy
anywhere else and so as you're biking
towards it you can see like I'm biking
into a cloud I'm biking into a cloud and
the experience of being in this place um
yeah I actually wonder I'm not sure
um if this isn't an earlier one with one
that felt like an actual rainbow so is
that this the other day okay okay if
this is the other day then fascinating
that once again what you know what I'm
seeing on the screen here looks looks
actually more colorful although still
not brightly colored as are um it was
basically I was entirely in a fog bank
and yet I could see this this bow above
me or you know in front of me picture
which is not very clear but it sort of
demonstrates the fog yeah so and so
you're just seeing the top of the top of
the bow on this one I think what's going
on is that in general when you see well
actually this is interesting because
it's the Counterpoint to what I saw
driving I wonder if that rainbow isn't
far enough from you that the very
unusual Cloud bank that forms in that
particular part of the island obscured
yeah that it basically Grays out so
you're seeing a light intensity
difference because the light is being
broken up into spectrums that you're
differentially sensitive to but it's
being basically projected on a a gray uh
atomizer of light but that does suggest
that that rainbow might perhaps have
been farther from you than the one that
I was seeing so that's interesting so I
guess the question is what we need and
actually
probably I don't know how I can do it
but there's got to be a way to figure
out
like the water droplets that are
breaking apart the light that we see as
a rainbow are actually some distance
from you right right it seems like a
rainbow is nowhere but it isn't nowhere
right the the particular raindrops that
interacted with the particular rays of
light are somewhere but there are
conditions which make it possible for
many people to have individual rainbows
right
so so it is somewhere in some place um
but it is not everywhere in every place
right and it is some distance from you
and it would be interesting to figure
out how you can you can determine the
distance because you can't just do it
based on the simple size of the thing
because of course the angle of the light
is going to affect the size of the thing
relative to your field of view um but
there's got to be some set of
observations you could make three or
four things that would allow you to
isolate yeah the things that broke up
the light that I saw were 15 MERS from
me or a mile from me or a foot from me
yeah be interesting to know but it it
actually makes the more General point if
you were blessed enough to be an
ancestor with access to rocks that were
magnetic and by the way let me just
explain why that would be the
case all rocks are composed of molecules
that have two poles but they are
chaotically distributed such that they
cancel each other out and there's no net
magnetism so you just don't feel it most
of the time every so often a geological
phenomenon like the melting something
will allow those atoms or will cause
those atoms to become aligned in some
way right like
imagine I don't even know what what
would be doing it the the alignment of
the Earth's magnetic field the
liquefication of something that causes
you to have an alignment so that all the
Norths are pointing one way all the
souths are pointing another way and you
you know this but I find
magnetism about as difficult to parse as
anything it's really I'm going to be of
no help here I obviously don't have it
don't I got like right Rule and that's
about it right but the point is most
humans would not have access to magnetic
rock they wouldn't encounter one in
their entire life right some people
would have access to some rock that they
could reliably go to over a lifetime be
like hey let me show you this you know
yeah and you need yeah you would need
two rocks or a piece of metal or
something but um but anyway the point is
how many of these things are there that
suggest a level of physics that is not
implied by regular stuff right you've
got rainbows you've got magnets you've
got um the procession of a top you've
got projection of the Sun during an
annual Eclipse during an annual Eclipse
exactly all of these things imply
another layer and all of the greates
tsunamis sure there you go yeah the
uncompress ability of water and its
relationship to between earthquakes and
tsunamis that sort of thing um
sublimation right of of one plate under
another is no no oh you're talk oh
sublimation like if you live if you live
near a a glacier yeah most people I I
think what is subduction is what I was
you um but sublimation the change of a
solid to a gas without going through a
liquid right most humans would probably
have no experience of that in an entire
lifetime because the changes aren't
abrupt in this way right um you know and
you know you do have experience as a
modern uh the ice in your freezer
dehydrating yeah yeah if if you don't if
you don't work through your ice a lot
the ice ends up a weird it's it's a it
becomes a weird consistency and a weird
taste because whatever lands on the
surface over all the months that it sits
in your freezer gets concentrated in on
an Ever smaller surface area um but
anyway what is that list of things that
imply a deeper physics and what
relationship do they have to the way
that we came to understand how all of
the physics of the universe works and
what sort of
Developmental Works caused the people
who focused on these things and were
like no hey wait a minute that that
means something right um yes yeah we we
we could invoke M mysticism or how would
we know but the people who simply did
that didn't make progress in their
understanding right and for some of
these things it might be hard to imagine
what the Practical use of understanding
is uh but for most of them I mean even
even if there is no practical use for a
particular thing having the mindset both
individually and culturally of huh I
wonder why H what's going on there is
exactly the thing uh that predicts
whether or not those people and that
individual will actually uh become Adept
in the world right and it's it's
actually the defense of what we used to
call basic science right right the point
is the people who pursued these things I
mean maybe there were some of them that
were hell bent on getting ahead but
that's not what does it what does it is
God damn it what does that mean I've got
to know right I'm going to pursue this
because it's going to drive me crazy
until I figure it out yeah what we used
to call and still due to some degree
basic science as opposed to applied
science and it's really you know you
know stem right stem is necessary but um
the math is fundamental and the science
Builds on the math and a lot of science
Builds on math so remotely that you
don't actually necessarily need to know
the math that it's building on um Math
and Science um are not inherently
applied at all y whereas the two middle
initials in that acronym Tech and
Engineering are inherently the applied
versions and
increasingly um and you know I think I
think one of the reasons that many
people end up thinking I'm not good at
science I don't do science and and math
too but let's just stick with science um
here because it's it's it's our millu
more more intimately and more
fundamentally um many people end up
believing that they're not good at
science and then it has no relevance to
them uh because the way it is taught to
them and the way it is revealed into the
world is actually an applied what is the
purpose here the things you need to
memorize uh here's what we already know
here are the facts and none of those
things are are inherent to science right
it's it's not a memory game it's not a
what is the fact ma'am um and it's not a
what use will that will this be to to us
and you know so you know if if we we
would give up a fair amount of our
modern conveniences if the T and the e
in stem disappeared
obviously but instead what we're seeing
is the Shaving away of the S we're
seeing a a Tim Focus now in many places
too many places as if the science
without the obvious application without
the obvious uh focus on rope
memorization um is kind of old school
that's so last century who needs it
anyway and everything else will collapse
without it certainly the engineering and
the technology will but everything else
will collapse without it and I mean this
is this is one of the Grave errors of
the 21st century is abandoning the S and
stem and it is actually making us um I
don't want to say measurably because
that may be the one thing it doesn't do
but it is making us absolutely stupider
absolutely it absolutely stupider and is
making us so much more likely to be uh
played which is what is happening to us
again and again because people all the
domains it's like they think that
science is about absorbing what we've
learned through this mechanism that they
don't really understand and don't get
good at using absorbing what we've
already learned and applying it to
things that make our lives better right
which mean well how would you do that
well I guess I would ask the experts in
this field and then they would tell me
and then I will report it as if I'm
intelligent and the answer is no
actually you're you're you're
propagating propaganda because you can't
tell the difference because you don't
have a detector that works
because nobody taught you how to think
and and oh by the way most of the
experts don't know the difference either
right they're they're the they're the
lead dummies but right what you know so
here's the problem MH the the a that
there's a list of phenomena that implies
a second layer to what drives
reality
um obviously the way if you really
wanted to
make you know really smart people you
would expose them to these things in
isolation from the ability to look up
why they are the way they are and the
question is well how can you figure out
what this is and you may not get all the
way there but as we used to do and when
we were professors right right so you
know the the the don't look it up
phenomenon we have used as a title is
obviously a a path not taken with
respect to how education should work um
but what a missed opportunity and I do
wonder if the
um obviously increasing stupidity and
pettiness of planet Earth is not in part
Downstream from just this one simple uh
bit of spreading myopia that you know
science is something science is a matter
of listening to The Experts um which it
just ain't
right well
um that was unexpected and uh enjoyable
yeah and um I'm
wondering if we want to go next
to Roger Waters all right uh was there
some there there are a number of other
things we were we thinking about going
to today but um I think it's a
reasonable thing to do and I actually
think that what we just did is pretty
pretty good as an intro to it I I do
have to ask people uh for a little bit
of
leash because there's a way in which um
Roger Waters has become such a flasho
and this week is such a terrible
terrible week in the history of planet
Earth especially if you uh feel deeply
the predicament of the Middle East
especially
Israel um that in some sense I can full
well understand the perspective that
whatever may be true of Roger Waters and
his insights or lack thereof that this
ain't the week to be hearing from him I
can imagine that as a rational response
and there's a part of me that feels the
same way but the reason I say some leash
is that I want people who know us to
trust that we're exploring this for a
reason and the reason has to do with um
what good might be done by treading in
this difficult uh Arena at this moment
of um maximum
difficulty let me just say we're not
going to show Roger
waters's video it's just it's too long I
do encourage people to go look at it um
but I will describe it he just he put
out if you want to show the screenshot
here Zach um he just put out a five
minute um video about
um a five minute video about effectively
um well what he is thinking I think it
was dated October 11th so as of 4 days
after um the Hamas attack on Israel yeah
um so anyway it takes the form of a an
open letter which he
reads and he describes his uh desire for
what he thinks should happen in the
Middle East which I regard as perfectly
Preposterous um and then his you find
perfectly Preposterous what he describes
as what should happen yes he basically
is calling for a ceasefire at a moment
when um you know you have more than a
thousand Israeli citizens dead under the
most barbaric intentionally barbaric
circumstances conceivable and I don't
know how many hostages there are but a
huge number of people imperil in what we
know are terrible circumstances and are
probably worse than we can imagine but
you know ceasefire is just an incoherent
idea at this
moment that said um I want to explore a
little bit the status of Roger Waters I
have
um said some things about the man and I
want people to understand all of the
related and uh implied connections can I
just uh
I honestly have no idea to what degree
our audience may not be familiar with
what a Roger Waters is I I have no idea
so um let me just say he was um one of
the by by some estimations um the lead
creative uh Talent uh in Pink Floyd um
at least after Sid Barrett was no longer
part of it uh and um you know pink pink
Floy the band uh of course
was an
extraordinarily uh insightful and
unusual band in an era in the late 60s
7s through they put out their final
album The Final Cut in 1983 um in an era
of unusually uh insightful bands but
they were you know they were unique
among uh among unique entities and they
were let let me just say um they they
happened to be um you know one of the
only bands that I actually listened to
ever in high school because of my
upbringing mostly with classical music
and then I found them and went
these people speak to me in a way that
um and it was mostly I was listening to
music that had been put out well before
you know my time um not well before my
time but many years to a couple decades
um enough so that actually one of the
very few concerts I actually went to um
literally the night before I started
college I drove several hours to see
Roger Waters live in concert um so this
you know this this is a music and
musician and an U that has been
extraordinarily meaningful yes and I
would say also deeply meaningful to me
and I would say unambiguously meaningful
to us you and I bonded over a shared
appreciation for this uh when we met in
high school yeah so and I would just
change one thing about what you
presented about the history I really
think you need to think about Pink Floyd
as two bands there's the Sid Barrett
band and then there's what happened when
Sid Barrett effectively lost his mind
left the band and then there's the uh
Roger Waters and Gilmore band that
followed yeah
um and you know most of the albums that
people know the wall Dark Side of the
Moon are in that second version of Pink
Floyd Wishy were here yeah Wishy were
here right animals yeah wish you were
here which is actually
um written it is about Sid Barrett I
believe the idea is it is it is Roger
waters's lament that his friend s
Barrett is not present yeah I think it
may be but any anyway
um so Roger Waters has a kind of complex
status in my mind and I wanted to
explore this because I think especially
this week we are seeing first of all I
mean if there's there's so much evil
that has been uh we are forced to
Grapple with in light of the attack by
Hamas on
Israel um that there's you know there's
no shortage of terrible outgrowths of
these events if there's one positive
thing in my opinion it is that the
anti-Semitism that some of us have been
seeing and trying to call attention to
is no longer a rumor now everybody has
seen it it has been uh you know the
celebrations in uh the street across the
world tell you these are not people
simply
celebrating uh a a surprise attack these
are people who know what happened in
that attack and are not embarrassed by
it they are not troubled by it and that
is
so um the implications of it could
hardly be more profound these are people
who have zero empathy for the victims
there even though the victims were
innocent these were not this is not the
Israeli government about which we could
talk about what what role they did or
didn't play in setting the stage for
this but literally innocent people
including children and no empathy for
them whatsoever so the anti-Semitism
that many of us have been seeing and
trying to raise the alarm about is now
visible to many people who couldn't see
it before and that is
um a tiny positive thing compared to the
horror that we've seen but it is
important because it's going to play a
role going forward it it it is important
and I've I've heard individually uh from
people who um are extraordinarily
sympathetic um um to to Israel uh who
are saying now I've been hearing Brett
talk about him seeing arise in
anti-Semitism and I haven't seen it and
I didn't disbelieve that he was seeing
it right um you know these I'm not
talking about you know haters or
disbeliever I'm just talking about
people who are saying I hadn't seen it I
didn't know what he was seeing uh it was
cryptic and now it's not cryptic yeah
and people are reporting not just what
we are seeing in public but just at the
individual level
of people who others thought were
friends aren't reaching out to ask is
your family
okay right um it they're it's like the
veil has fallen and it has one one
friend of mine from Portland uh said um
it feels a little bit like what it felt
like in Portland in mid
2021 when everyone had gotten be so many
people had gotten behind the everyone
must get vaccinated or else their evil
people and uh this
is more terrifying yet and more H it is
and I hope um two things have happened
one people who uh
um have no anti-Semitism to them at all
couldn't see it and didn't know what to
make of it and this week they are seeing
it and it is causing them to think a new
right which is good but there's another
thing that I hope will happen which I
haven't seen yet but my guess is if I
under if I read the landscape correctly
this is almost certain to happen at
least in enough cases to matter there
are people good people who have been
traversing the edges of this
anti-semitic landscape they have been
trying to understand what to think about
the presence of Jews in organizations
that they see as hostile to humanity in
karma in government people and right and
they're trying to understand what to do
with it and they are getting they are
trafficking in these sort of shallow end
of the pool anti-semitic tropes they are
trafficking in Ive responsibility and
guilt which is really the sinan Nan of
anti-Semitism of of all of the
bigotry uh that does population level
broad brush if you're a member of EX you
must be because X has done bad things if
you are a member of X you are a bad
thing yourself instead of recognizing
that there are bad Jews of which there
are many mhm saying the Jews that's the
place where you cross the line and the
point point is and we will get back to
the lineage level thing which takes Jews
out of this entirely and just says
actually this is an evolutionary
question that applies to an old style of
interaction that all of us come from
yeah all of our ancestors did this but
anyway we'll come back to that in a
second what I'm hoping is that some of
the good people who have been
experimenting at The Fringe of this very
bad style of thought this very dangerous
style of thought will actually be made
aware of what slippery slope they are
standing on the edge of and they will
say
oh I don't want to be there that's not
me that's a violation of my own values
and they will step back from that slip
slippery slip I really hope that happens
because there are a lot of people that I
do regard as uh fundamentally good who
are experimenting with some
fundamentally bad ideas and it is not
helpful yeah um but back to back to
Roger
Waters um I said a couple weeks ago on
Twitter and I do have a slight regret
about the way I said it I was trying to
defend Roger waters's right to speak he
had been Uninvited to speak I think at
the University of
Pennsylvania um and I because he had
been playing with Nazi tropes yeah but
that's actually a bad but but that isn't
that that was the stated reason I think
so we haven't said that yet I think the
stated reason was
anti-Semitism the claims about his
playing with Nazi tropes are absurd
okay he's not playing with Nazi troops
this is somebody who is resolutely
anti-nazi and at a at a familial level
right this is a person his father died
fighting the Nazis right his father died
fighting the Nazis and he has been
anti-nazi and he has been portraying
Nazis as the evil sons of that
they were in his art for his entire
history so that's a bad rap okay I don't
think that that is that his you know
putting on Nazi costumes and shooting at
the audience is about him harboring Nazi
sympathies that's really really wrong
but I do think and I said in defending
his right to speak what I what I said
was that back when I was at Penn Lewis
farakhan had come to speak and we all
knew he was an anti-semite and we went
anyway and I'm glad I did and I don't
want to see Roger Waters shut down
because of anti-Semitism I think he
should be allowed to speak and people
should go listen yeah so I understood
myself to be defending him but but I did
acknowledge that I believed after all of
the evidence that I had seen that in
fact he did Harbor anti-Semitism but I
want to be really clear about what that
does and does not mean to me because I
have a feeling that when people hear a
Jewish person say that somebody is an
anti-semite it implies things to them
that are not at least inherently true so
you have heard you the audience have now
heard Heather and me talk about the fact
that Roger Waters and Pink Floyd have a
special import to us and unlike some of
the stuff that I listened to back then I
actually still find that importance many
of it many of those things you age out
of them being useful they're just not
insightful anymore when you become older
and wiser Pink Floyd there's still a lot
of value it actually stands up really
well and I go back and I listen to that
stuff with regularity because it is
Meaningful so what does that mean that
I'm saying that this person who is
responsible for things that I hold dear
I believe Harbor's anti-Semitism even
though I'm a Jew and that's means that I
believe he has some bias against people
like me some uh unreasoned bias some
emotional bias that is not founded on
facts
well let me just lay it out a I think
um we have not done a good job we
civilization have not done a good job
figuring out what we think about the
difference between binary categories and
Spectra right the fact that sex is being
claimed to be a spectrum and that that's
obviously tactical and sex isn't a
spectrum so we see the claim that
something has a is a spectrum as sort of
inherently suspect because we know that
we can be tricked by people you know
parading
Spectra well anti-Semitism is an actual
Spectrum there is rabid anti-Semitism
people who just think Jews should be
wiped out and we've seen them uh
chanting and celebrating in streets
across the world um there is an entire
range to a flight suspicions that
certain people Harbor um that uh affect
interactions and I have never thought
that uh that Waters was a rabid
anti-semite in any way I just think he
has a little bit of bias that is you
know no doubt tied up in complex
feelings about the loss of his father
and the nature of World War II and who
knows whatever else um and the friends
he happens to have made um are more
likely to be Palestinians than Israelis
and I I mean I think that ends up
predicting some amount of of this that
if you know if you know someone with a
personal story and they are on this side
rather than that you are more likely to
see that as the enemy who is doing ill
in the
world so for those who would ask why I
think this after looking at lots of
statements of waters looking at his
desire you know in his art he does stuff
he dresses up as a Nazi and he shoots at
the audience um as he is very clearly um
portraying Nazis as villains right so
this is a guy whose art includes the
portrayal of enemies for the purpose of
the audience drawing the correct
conclusion about them but he also you
know the Flying Pig that flies above his
uh concerts he you know has put Jewish
stars on them they drop money uh you
know he's had phrases put on them that
are anti-semitic now it could be that
this is Roger Waters doing the same
thing he's doing when he uh puts on a
Nazi outfit and attempting to call
attention to anti-Semitism but it
doesn't seem like that and what's more
the thing that really caused me to draw
a conclusion at all
was people he has known well who report
that in their interactions anti-Semitism
is apparent to them including David
Gilmore right so I don't think he's a
rabid
anti-semite and if we can get back to
what he lays out in this um letter of
his is letter uh it actually gives us
kind of an insight as to where he is the
letter he
is defending he is both putting
proposals on the table which make no
sense in light of where we are but he is
also describing the world that he wishes
to see and I guess I would actually just
ask people who are trying to figure out
what to do with Roger Waters to draw the
following
dichotomy this is not a man with any
demonstrated capacity to understand the
the difficulties that block us from
getting from A to B however this is
somebody with a very highly developed
capacity to describe where it is that we
should
goh and so put aside completely I in my
opinion his suggestion of solution his
his his solution making his process
oriented solution making but take very
seriously Roger Waters dream and he
describes it as a dream in this piece
because Roger Waters has had interesting
dreams uh over the course of many years
and he has often put them
into his art and those
dreams you know for our audience members
let me just say that I am
somebody who people often tell me that
I'm very
articulate I believe that the reason
that I am articulate if in fact I am has
a lot to do with um word play word play
that came in the form
of uh playful banter at the dinner table
but maybe even more importantly um I pay
very close attention to artfully
constructed lyrics that are meaningful
that convey something important and do
so in a way that lodges them in the mind
special
and in in any case Waters has outlined
various dreams these are not things that
Roger Waters knows how to accomplish
right they may not even be reasonable
places that could exist but he has
outlined some things in ways that
resonate for those of us who hear them
and in one partic so in the in the
letter here that he he newly provides he
describes in effect a vision of a world
after these conflicts are uh put to
rest and that world is what I'm
calling the
West this is a world in which everybody
is equally protected by the structures
and just everybody is equally protected
from the structures and protected in a
way that liberates them do I believe
that if rer Waters was in a all powerful
position to construct that world would
he do it yes do I believe that he would
include Jews in that world in which
everybody was equally protected I do
believe that he would do that there
might be some little nagging thing that
he would feel that that was injust
perhaps but nonetheless I do think that
he is telling it like it is with respect
to what world he would like to see see
and that he is a bit confused about the
world as it is and he is confused about
the rules that would allow us to get
there but um I did want to point out one
particular thing uh from a
uh I think it is from the wall it has to
be from the wall um I wanted to point to
a set of lyrics that I have known since
you and I met that's uh a long time ago
um it is from a song that I think is
called the Gunner's dream the Gunner's
dream is the Final Cut oh it's the Final
Cut yeah all right
um it I know that right away just
because you and I talked about the
Gunner's dream earlier and I and I went
back and listen to it yeah I was I had
the feeling it was on the final cup but
then it narratively fits in with many of
the things on the wall which is why I
was confused but the Final Cut collects
many of the things that were cut from
earlier albums I believe oh I don't know
that yeah um but anyway the the Gunner's
dream is obviously a reference to his
father um his father who died in World
War II in Italy um I believe was shot
down
and in the letter that Waters uh
released yesterday um he refers to his
father uh and the death of his father
fighting the Nazis and he refers to his
father's dream which he says he shares
so in the Final Cut boy I'm a little
concerned about singing this for one
thing uh still fighting that cof and for
another thing it always breaks me up a
little bit for reasons that I think will
become obvious yeah um so it starts out
um this is first two yeah yeah um a
place to stay well hold on hold on uh
floating
down through the
clouds my memories come rushing up to
meet me now and in the space between the
heavens and the corner of some foreign
field I had a
dream I had a
dream a place to
stay enough to
eat somewhere old Heroes Shuffle safely
down the street where you can speak out
loud about your doubts and fears and
what's more no one ever disappears
you'll never hear their standard issue
kicking in your door you can relax on
both sides of the tracks and
Maniacs don't blow
holes in bandsmen by remote control and
everyone has recourse to the
law and no one kills the children
anymore so
Roger Waters describes the west and he
does it very
eloquently there are things included in
those few lines that
are beautiful in their compassion the
fact that he carves
out a place for war
heroes in a world without
War
and the idea in in the Same album in
which he puts war criminals in a home
for the Fletcher Memorial Home for
incurable pants and Kings
yep so this is important for a number of
reasons the outline of what the West is
is vital and people are losing track of
it and when I talk about the fact that
lineage versus lineage violence is in a
position to dislodge our understanding
of the West and to replace it because
although the West is better it is safer
it is fairer it is less violent it is
more productive it is more liberating it
is highly desirable for any human being
to join something that is a stable
version of the west but it is fragile it
is easily vetoed by people who have
something else in
mind Waters is laying out picture of the
West and one of the things as I Revis
visited these lyrics for the first time
in some time today what I realized is
the
tragedy of how much farther we are from
that description than we were even 25
years ago the idea you and I spend a lot
of time
worrying about what we say and what its
impact on our safety will
be the idea that he
expresses where you can speak out loud
about your doubts and fears we cannot
speak out loud about our doubts and
fears not in safety anyway that is a
tragedy that we have lost that he talks
about everyone has recourse to the law
that is not true anymore that is that is
a reality that we had within our grasp
and it is slipping away because
something else has taken home
and no one kills the children anymore
exactly and the point is this week you
can see the status of children in this
even the mafia leaves children
out we are somewhere so desperately
dangerous um
so
um I was going to sing stanza go for it
uh from later in the Same
album which is
I think reflective of what many people
are feeling right now
um the eponymous track from the album
the final
cut through the fishey lens of tear
stained
eyes I can barely Define the shape of
this moment in
time and far from Flying high in Clear
Blue Sky
I'm spiraling down to the hole in the
ground where I
[Music]
hide this is where so many people are
right
now it does not
provide a solution does not provide a
way
forward that is the stanza of this album
that stuck with me the most from the 80s
when I first heard it
as I understand it was written
autobiographically this is something
that was supposed to be in the wall at
first um and it is written by someone
who is desperate who is dark who is uh
at risk of ending
himself which is never a place that I
was that was never me uh and yet this
always
resonated
how and you know and it's poetry as so
much of what Waters rights is
I can barely Define the shape of this
moment in
time this is what we are all trying to
do and we are being told what the shape
of this moment in time is we're being
told that some things are true that
can't be and we are being told that this
is just like what has happened before
and there's nothing new here
no no well let's let's say this I
believe that we can be we thinking
people we people who have not lost our
minds in last
week can be certain that we are being
had yeah we do not know who we are being
had by right at the very least we can
say that Hamas has engaged in an attack
that it deliberately constructed to
produce an overwhelming response why it
wanted that overwhelming response we
don't know who its Partners were we
don't know but the point is at the very
least we are being had that somebody as
diabolical as that is in the position to
Define what the rest of the world is
allowed to do right that is
intolerable as for what we should do we
should think more carefully and um those
of you who've been following me on
Twitter know that I've been actually
more successfully than I was expecting
conveying the importance of
understanding that there are two ways we
can go forward neither of them is Rosie
Kumbaya they are both versions of human
competition but one of them is Honorable
and productive and is actually the forge
of very good things and the other one is
diabolical and terrible and the stuff of
all of the tragedies of history and we
are literally
standing well we are sitting therefore
we are not literally standing but we are
we are literally faced you know we are
figuratively standing and faced with a
choice between two
Futures resc it sort of
um we are faced with two Futures and we
really have to choose but I
swear the idea that people have the
power to put you in a bind where you are
told you have both one choice that is
them controlling you to the extent that
there is but one choice
that is something that you don't know
something you've never met deciding on
your fate a wise person a wise Nation a
wise Planet would never allow that to
happen I do not mean this to be
trivializing but I'm reminded of the
words of Johnny ksh in a live I don't
remember if he's at I think he's at one
of his prison concerts I don't remember
it's San Quenton maybe but he says
speaking to the audience before asking
them to the inmates his audience uh
asking them what they wanted to sing he
says J is being broadcast to England and
they're telling me where to stand and
what to sing and everything and I just I
don't play like that says you put the
screws on me I'm going to screw right
out from under you yeah I remember that
yeah and I mean this is it right like it
you know you you tell me exactly what I
need to
do and actually the move should
be not if it's man M at by you right it
it has to be because if if if we are
ever in a position of saying well we had
we had no choice we had to do the
barbaric thing
like create the choice you you have to
create the choice because I mean I think
you I really want you to be saying this
part but we were talking about this last
night like the part where the terrorists
do X and therefore we have only one
choice and it looks like we're
obliterating terrorists that is the
terrorists winning because they have set
your agenda for you yeah they are in
charge of your generals um so let me uh
I actually tweeted uh Zack will you put
up the tweet that I sent you yes I I
think I more or less captured
it so what I said is if terrorists can
force the hand of Mighty Nations through
acts of unimaginable barbarism during
directed against civilians we should
expect ever more shocking acts of
barbarism to be inflicted on civilians
as terrorists struggle to maintain
control of the mighty armies they
command and just because a couple people
misunderstood it the armies that they
command are the armies of the mighty
Nations they are not the terrorist
forces my point is they have effectively
gained control of you
know a modern Army by telling it what it
has no choice but to do and I would also
point
out um many people are botching the
analysis
of what Israel should do what the world
should do on the basis that the moral
situation here is clear at the most
basic level right the barbarism of the
ACT leaves zero moral ambiguity
whatsoever about the perpetrator
what we don't know we know who some of
the perpetrators are Hamas are
perpetrators are they the only
perpetrators we don't know the status of
Iran is
ambiguous if Iran
is responsible for this act more than
just favorable towards this act then
that puts it in a
position uh of moral identity with those
who committed the ACT likewise if these
Hamas members trained outside of Gaza
maybe they trained in Iran that would be
one thing but maybe they trained
somewhere else but in essence there's a
question of who is on the list of people
responsible for this and that is a very
it is a question that we must get right
and we cannot wait to get it right that
does not mean that Israel should hold
its fire fire relative to Hamas but it
does mean that no exploration of
culpability is complete until you have
the full list of people who are actually
culpable wherever they come from so
uh I I'm troubled by the failure of
people to spot that second question
because the first question is so clear
and people don't all get it right
they're so interested in in the
certainty of the moral question which is
frankly a simple one that they um Mis
understand that there are other
questions that actually have to be asked
at this moment
which I don't know how to make this
point it seems to me this is this is if
there's any point that shouldn't need to
be made it's this
one how many famous examples would we
need of places where great Nations went
to war
under false pretenses for us to get the
idea that anytime you are Marching to
war you have to investigate the question
of whether somebody is actually leading
you to do their bidding and you are
operating on the basis of a moral
Clarity uh for somebody else's cynical
gain and I would just point out um you
know remember the main right the sinking
of the Maine in The Havana Harbor the
konkan Gulf incident weapons of mass
destruction in Iraq the list of these
things is long and it extends well into
modernity so the idea that we should not
be asking those questions now no this is
the only time to be asking those
questions as you are Marching to war
figuring out whose bidding you are doing
is essential right we must be
unflinching about that for now and
forever after there is no question about
it because the demonstrated Capac
capacity of people to drive us to War
under false pretenses is unambiguous it
is just historically clear if there is
any pattern that is clear this is it so
I do wonder how we have forgotten that
lesson I think people are under some
kind of spell it does feel like a a mass
formation spell that has people arguing
viciously in many cases not to ask these
questions and those people are
wrong
no one can make out the shape of this
moment in time and those who are trying
are being told to sit down and shut up
already yes they are being told to sit
down and shut up already and I must say
um I was very unhappy to see some of the
push back that uh IFR fixon got for our
podcast people accused her of all sorts
of things like Mis portraying her level
of expertise which she absolutely did
not do she did not portray herself as an
expert she explained exactly what her uh
understanding was based on and the
audience because the audience is
composed of people with a brain is full
well capable of placing her uh
understanding in context what's
more nothing about what concerned people
in that podcast is dependent
on Expert Insight in other words if I
may
just paint and
uh an uncomfortable
parallel the what would be necessary to
explain the failure of the
IDF to either protect the Border or to
have a rapid reaction force that could
cover for the fact that it had failed to
protect the
border
is
um implausible in a way that we have not
uh seen before
and my point is simply if you try to the
idea that there's something that we
don't know because we're not insiders
and that it is somehow vital to our
understanding of whether or not what
took place makes sense or doesn't make
sense according to the version of events
we've been uh portrayed is not plausible
it doesn't make sense you would have to
have you know some explanation where you
know the entire IDF where the entire uh
governance structure of the IDF had
decided to take hallucinogenic drugs for
a month and that's why they missed it
right you need some industrial strength
explanation that just is nowhere uh
nowhere inside so anyway I will leave
that uh question aside but I do think in
asking
um how we got here who is it that wants
us to make what moves and by us I just
mean all of the parties involved which
frankly involves everyone on Earth we
all have interests tied up in this
situation um but it is
uh it is very important that we not
forget what we knew even a few years ago
and if there's one lesson that acrosses
all of the crises we've seen in recent
history it's that people very quickly
forget things that they understood very
very well that are important to
defending their uh interests in the
world and we are in the process of doing
that and uh we have to cut it
out so there are a number of other
things we were thinking about talking
about today and I think will save most
of the but uh you specifically wanted to
discuss one thing that you think we used
to all know that we have forgotten do do
you want to go there um sure since that
is what you were just talking about you
just didn't get to the punch line that I
thought complete the thought yeah um I
am spooked by the fact that
we are not as far as I can tell I
haven't heard any you know I obviously
haven't read everything um but I have
not heard just discussion of the status
of the neocons in the current
scenario now the neocons for those who
aren't real familiar with that term were
a group of uh
American uh thought leaders for lack of
a better term um
ferociously
pro-israel but
also uh decidedly in favor of using a
American Military might to reorganize
the Middle East right these were people
who claimed that they were liberals who
had been mugged by reality and had grown
up and realized the world was a
dangerous place and that if we were
going to make it a better place we were
going to have to go use American
Military might to fix
stuff you know Paul Wolowitz uh Bill
Crystal David from all sorts of folks
nor potates um
so the the question is the reason I
raised this question is that back in the
post 911
era the idea that there were a series of
wars that needed to be fought um that
would make the world a better safer
place in the end and that the adults
understood this it's kind of the neocon
line
and they
wanted to go into Iraq they wanted to go
into
Iran they didn't get their war in Iran
because the war in Iraq and Afghanistan
turned into quagmires and bankrupted us
and there was just no way that they were
going to do it
so they sort of disappeared from view
for a
while and they're not in view now really
I mean we know you know we see their
Twitter accounts but they're not being
discussed as players in this game and in
fact you know some of them have died and
you know maybe maybe they're just not
players in this game and they're
Spectators like the rest of us but I
don't think that that's in any way
certain and in fact I have the sense
that one of the things you know time has
moved on the neocons are now on the blue
team that's an interesting development
right they're partnered with the blue
team right so what that means is that as
power shifted from the red team to The
Blue Team the neocons moved over to the
blue team so they're still in power in
some way um and the question is okay
we're being told that a war with Iran is
necessary because Iran Iran U backed
this uh Hamas attack by
Hamas um
well you
know I I don't know what's true but what
I do want to know is that a group of
people who had an idea 20 years ago that
American Military might was going to be
necessary to reorganize the Middle East
and that involves going after Iran at
some point point I want to know that
they are not driving us to do that very
thing in a moment in which the world is
maximally hospitable to the idea that
something has to be done because of the
barbarism of Hamas um Etc
so
uh I don't know what to make of this I
guess I'm hoping people will connect
some
dots what is the neocon role at the
moment why are we not talking talking
about the fact that something that they
wanted and didn't get many years ago is
now back on the table as a result of
events that we are told to compel us
right is that happen stance could well
be but it is not inherently happen
stance and is there a new generation of
neocons that don't fly under that banner
and so we don't think of them in this
way who might be uh advancing these
ideas in places that we should be aware
that they are not just simply responding
to events but that actually there is
potentially some
um private analysis shared between them
and not with us that suggests uh a
requirement you know I would imagine it
would be phrased in a similar way that
you know the adults understand it's a
dangerous World certain things have to
occur this is the moment in which they
are possible because the world is now
sympathetic blah blah blah blah blah is
that conversation
happening and is that conversation
driving us in ways that we can't hear it
out here in public because we all have
everything at stake here right I keep
saying we are in a battle between the
west and lineage displacement these are
the two versions of the world going
forward we have everything at stake in
what happens and the problem is that the
Middle East is in a position to drag us
back into lineage displacement
competition right which will be a
disaster for all of us and and if we are
to protect our interests our interests
involve my podcast with if front I said
Israel has a foot in both of these
worlds I think Israel given the freedom
to choose would choose to be a modern
Western Nation but it may not have the
freedom to choose because of it its
context
so I don't know how to I don't know how
to put it any more clearly the world's
interests are tied up in this battle in
the Middle East
and the Dynamics are not symmetrical
it's not like good will prevail in fact
I think what is most likely to happen is
that evil will prevail and evil will
prevail in the form of a return that
will spread across the globe to lineage
displacement competition right all of
the tragedies of History arise out of
that bad pattern and if we are to avoid
them we have to become aware of it and
we have to
uh start navigating based on a long-term
view of what's good for humans
indeed um all right I
think I agree with you I don't think I
have anything to add I think I think
we've arrived at the end cross many of
rubicons um I don't think that's how
that works
but yeah I don't really know either but
um all right uh we'll be back with
another live stream in 3 days uh Tuesday
at 11:30 a.m.
Pacific and we will have a private Q&A
tomorrow on Sunday October 15th uh at
11:00 a.m. Pacific uh which you can uh
join us at at our locals I encourage you
to join us there for all sorts of
reasons um other things are still true
you can find my writing at Natural
Selections uh you can find merchandise
uh including getting your Jake's micro
Pizza shirt at Darkhorse store.org Yum
Yum Yum yeah uh Jake's micro Pizza comes
in all the flavors you have uh come to
expect at your favorite pizza parlor uh
it is a little smaller than you will
have come to expect but uh just like
regular pizza only tast GE and much much
much smaller so much smaller yes um
Jake's micro pizza I'll put on my mask
when I'm done
eating um so yeah you can get that and
other things at Darkhorse store.org
um a reminder um check out our sponsors
this week uh if you have an interest in
new kind of dpris biome uh new kind of
dog food Sundays and also yum also yum
apparently Brett has tried it and a new
kind of seed uh a new kind of seed a new
kind of probiotic seed um and they're
all um interesting they're all actually
shelf stable um in a way that is not
scary uh which is unusual usually shelf
stability uh ends up uh causing all
sorts of trouble but put them on a
stable shelf yeah um I have one last
note before before we get to sign offs
you tell me when this is it go for it
okay uh the one final note I forgot to
say this uh if Roger Waters wants to
talk this through I think it could be
really cathartic for lots of people who
have ambiguous feelings and are trying
to work them out so I would absolutely
welcome that conversation um and uh
we'll probably be nearby soon Roger so
think about it and uh get in touch so um
please subscribe like share on Rumble
and elsewhere but Rumble and locals um
do us the most good and are the uh the
platforms that are most resistant to
censorship and most favor of free speech
of of any uh that we know and that we
are associated with so uh please come
join us at Rumble and locals and until
we see you next time be good to the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
apologies for the
singing
that